well I had to talk because we were
talking about our air fryer before this
yeah we were bonding over our air fryers
do you have an airplane don't everybody
these days I know right way that you can
reheat French fries and make them fit to
eat that's the trick
s
oh my God I'm telling you
I'm just I don't know if I can marry two
women but I might have to ask I mean
Dolly's worth Dolly's worth it
okay the only thing is you got to get
your spouse to clean it right like I
don't I don't clean the air fryer you
think I clean it no you don't know
but I eat it I love it I love it well
listen y'all are hosting the ACM 2023
together and I can't believe it but this
is the first time y'all are
collaborating together so tell me why
have y'all never collaborated before I
don't know why is that I don't know
because I can't believe we're
collaborating either because you know
Dolly's Dolly and she's just uh she's so
approachable yeah it's Dolly she's
Untouchable so it's very sweet for her
to uh to allow me to get to be a part of
this partnership yeah he's just a nobody
and I gotta tell you so far what I've
learned
she's funny and I love her humor so I
it's right down my alley it's twisted
sometimes a little bit bent and it's
like oh that's perfect for me I'm
because we both you know we both love
country music we've been at it for a
long time both of us and so and I've
always loved his music I've been a huge
fan seriously for years and uh it's just
one of those things that just I guess it
never happened because it was supposed
to happen now yeah I was talking about
you know how things are supposed to
happen when they're supposed to so who
knows where it might go from here we may
have Duets we may have a we may start
hosting all the shows she's gonna have
to bury me to lose me though
but honestly though I really think
there's a purpose for everything and I
just think this is a good time in life
he feels a lot like I do even just like
the song we're gonna that I'm performing
from Maraca of a missing Anthem about
lifting up the world and trying to heal
the Great Divide and he's so much like
that his heart's a lot like mine so I
really think that this was meant for a
higher purpose than us just hosting the
show and even if it's not it's still
going to be fun still gonna be fun I
mean this is your audition basically
with Dolly like maybe we'll get it maybe
we'll get a track maybe we'll get a
Christmas country album I'm just putting
it out there in the world I don't know
we were just talking that we never even
done anything together so who knows
something good she says no rules there's
no script for her she just look today's
my day I want to do this or do that so
uh I love that and I love to take the
journey I don't have to be the guy
leading I can also be the guy that's
following too so I I really enjoy this
this collaboration well there's no
following here
we're on equal ground here I just hope
that we do good for the fans out there
because we love the fans and we're going
to have a chance to really show some of
the great new artists coming along and
see some of our old friends like Keith
Urban and and uh Chris Stapleton who we
both love and so and then the new ones
it's like they kind of look up to some
of our some of us older artists maybe
seasoned I guess is better than old
Subway season I like a little season I
am a little older he's seasoned season
two Dolly but anyway so we're gonna look
forward to hearing them sing and to hear
the performances and seeing them get
their Awards and because he says a sweet
thing about what did you say about what
we remembered when you was talking about
because you remember when you're on
there right you remember when you get
your name called or or you get accepted
into the family it's very sweet so we
get to kind of get to share that and
relive all that with the new faces as
well I like Laney Wilson one of the new
ones I just did uh her we got a song we
did for the The Judds they're doing an
album yes for the judge for the mental
um
you know mental illness and some of the
problems that she had so they're doing a
whole album of the songs and I got to do
Mama He's Crazy with Lainey so and I
don't even know goodness so I'm going to
get a chance to visit she is probably so
excited because I actually had the
opportunity to sit down with Lainey and
she has her Mantra that is www Double D
what would Dolly do didn't even know
that yeah she lives by it she is going
to be oh my goodness this is gonna be
really exciting to see you that's what I
mean about the younger people kind of
having some of us older women should
look up what kind of like parents or
something to them yes but people can
talk about it all day but sometimes you
don't see it in their music you hear her
sing you are in her voice so that's yes
oh my gosh yes such a sweetest thing
Marshall on that my uh my heart is like
a truck or whatever yeah I love that
idea I heard it singing and I said to
somebody who's that saying I love that
song you know it's a good song it's so
catchy yeah
wait do you hear a talk that's where you
hurt me
yes okay well listen I mean Lainey
Wilson is the most nominated female
artist this year Hardy is the most
nominated male artist this year I mean
I'm sure they would love to get some
advice from y'all you've had such
beautiful careers what advice would you
give these these up and incoming artists
well we always say we don't give advice
we got information
we'll show you some information because
I do believe that people have their own
Journey their own way I really think you
have to find your way but it's good to
have some guidance and some information
so I guess advice is a good word but I
always when you say advice it's like
you're telling somebody how to do it or
do it like you because we all have to do
it our own way amen but there are basic
things you know that you have kind of
like the Golden Rule you know and just
stay true to yourself most of all and
your talent yeah my things have fun
and then since this females are a
perfect example I'm married to one of
them that that are like this of course
I'm married to a female you know what I
mean
um a woman in this business has to work
a thousand times harder to get a tent as
much they just do so any guys out there
I just tell them the fact that you're a
guy enjoy that Advantage it'll give you
but when it comes to work work like a
girl get out there
I look like a woman and think like a man
so I guess we're in the same spot
I love it well listen Garth this is your
first time hosting an award show I gotta
know what are the nerves like on a scale
of one to ten how are we feeling well
the great thing is it's Dolly right so
your nerves aren't as much as hosting
it's keeping up because you can read
that teleprompter all day
she's not going to be reading the
teleprompter she she believes in
structure because she's a pro but
they're going to be things she says that
aren't on there and now I'm guy I'm
screwed and I'm like what am I going to
do right so I'm gonna out there and just
try and swim and stay afloat it's going
to be stupid fun I'm I'm excited I just
want to be true to the artists and the
music and and the whole show but I'm not
going to be crazier we might be a little
goofy now and then I would have been a
little crazy
she's just hilarious she's just she's
just leering you in that she's gonna pop
no I don't really know what I'm going to
do
so don't let him figure he's acting like
he's never done no no no before come on
man that's Tarzan you know I think he's
pretty bold Garth Brooks AKA Tarzan I
like that I like that amazing well Dolly
you got a lot of people excited about
your performance you are premiering your
lead single from your upcoming rock star
album yeah I gotta know are we gonna see
leather are we going to have bigger hair
what's the look what can the fans expect
oh you've just gonna have to watch and
find out I'm sure I'm gonna have big
hair
these are good suggestions I'm trying to
you know I got to fit the performance
now if I was doing one of my real hard
rocking songs but this one has a message
so I won't be as crazy looking as I
might get when I sing some of the others
in videos or something but I'll have big
hair and I'll have whatever I need to
have to get this on across but I don't
want to take away from the message but
I'll be kind of costumey to fit the
theme of it absolutely all right well I
know you've got a lot of artists on this
album you've got Paul McCartney you've
got Stevie Nicks I mean the list goes on
but I hear you wanted Mick Jagger what
happened did Mick Jagger say no to Rocky
we just never he was doing an album we
just kept trying to figure out the song
I wanted to do satisfaction Can't Get No
Satisfaction and I did it but I did it
with pink and Brandy Carlisle and which
turned out fantastic because kind of
glad he didn't sing that one but anyway
then I wrote one just kind of you know
in his field of you know and then he he
didn't particular care for that one and
I just kept trying to come up with songs
and then he kept trying to find time to
do something but then we ran out of time
but I just run his little spindly legs
around like a little high school girl
after the jock and in school and I just
got tired of running and I just thought
well I guess I'll do something with him
next up I love it I love him though I've
always been a huge fan my husband loves
Mick Jagger and that's why I wanted to
do satisfaction with him because Carlton
loves that record but I didn't get all
the people I wanted but it wasn't
because they weren't willing to do it
it's just schedules and time this is
hard ain't it something to do well I
didn't know Garth and I know your next
thing is why in the hell didn't you ask
me
now they're going to do this I didn't
even it didn't even you know yeah I was
just trying to think of the rock you
know icons and all that you're just a
star and you know what there's time now
I wish I had now feel bad but I won't be
doing another one so you're just out can
you put me on your next laptop yes it's
like it's like once you've got to be
around her you just want to spend time
around her so it I look forward to the
future amazing
probably change your cell phone number
after this
Lord knows I'm not planning nothing I
just plan to be there plan to have you
with me and I'm excited about that oh
wonderful I think we deserve to have
this time
absolutely